welcome to the final part 4 of my
tutorial on how to solve a 5x5 Rubik's
Cube professor since you have now paired
up as many edges as possible without any
algorithms we must now determine whether
or not we have a parity error if you do
not have a parity error you will have a
cube that looks like the one I am
holding where all of the edge pieces
should be matched up properly and you
can therefore solve the cube exactly
like a 3x3 however the chances are very
good that you will encounter a parity
error when solving the cube and so
learning how to fix these errors is very
important you can tell that you have a
parity error if you have two or less
incomplete treads pieces with no
remaining unmatched pairs if you have
three or more mixed up dredges you can
keep on edge pairing until you have two
or less in which case you would
recognize that you have the parity error
or until you have matched up every
single edge piece and have a cube like
this one there are algorithms for every
different parity case however I assure
you that it is possible to fix the edge
parity errors with two algorithms which
is all I require you learn once you have
done so and fixed all the parity errors
the cube is identical to a 3x3 alright
so to start off there are three main
types of parity errors I'd like to
discuss the first one is a case where
there is only that one middle edge piece
that is flipped over this is comparable
to the case that we see in the 4x4 cube
where this dead piece has been flipped
over and we need to correct it in order
to complete the cross so you should
already know the algorithm I'm going to
use in order to correct this error
however I'm going to go through it step
by step we must first position that
flipped edge piece on the top layer
directly in front of us as it is
positioned here the move we are then
going to use is both right phases 180
degrees the back face 180 degrees the up
face 180 degrees both left faces
clockwise the up face 180 degrees both
right faces
counterclockwise
the up face 180 degrees both right faces
clockwise the up face 180 degrees the
front face 180 degrees both right faces
clockwise the front face 180 degrees
both left faces counterclockwise the
back face 180 degrees and both right
faces 180 degrees and as you'll see that
parody error which we had that piece
flipped is now corrected so now all of
the treasures are complete and we can
solve this cube exactly like a 3x3 so
now let's go over the next type of
parity error you will see another common
parity error you'll see is one way you
have to outer edge pieces which have
switched places
this outer red white piece needs to come
over here to complete the red white
tread
while this outer yellow blue piece needs
to go over there to complete the yellow
blue tread in order to fix this parity
error you must first make sure that
these two single outer edge pieces are
on the same layer if you have them on
opposite or different layers like that
you need to first arrange them so that
they are in the same layer before
continuing once they are on the same
layer we want to position them on the
top face all the way to the right of the
tread pieces that they're on so we want
it to look just like that we're then
going to perform the following algorithm
in order to correct the parity error so
we want to turn both left faces
counterclockwise the up face 180 degrees
both left faces counterclockwise the up
face 180 degrees the front face 180
degrees both left faces counterclockwise
the front face
a hundred and eighty degrees both right
faces clockwise the top face a hundred
and eighty degrees both right faces
counterclockwise the up face 180 degrees
and both left faces 180 degrees and as
you'll see that parody error in which
these pieces had been swapped that's now
corrected and this cube to me solved
exactly like a three by three the last
type of parity error you'll see is one
where we basically have the previous two
parity arrows together or even the same
parity error two or more times making
what looks like a randomized or
sometimes what's referred to as a
checkerboard pattern this type of parity
error is less common but it's a little
bit more involved however it can be
corrected using only one algorithm the
one which I used for the previous parody
case to swap those two outer edge pieces
so we don't have to use that really long
algorithm which I used in the first case
to flip that one middle edge piece over
however you can use it if you want to
the parody case I have on the left here
is a little easier since it already has
one edge pair while the parody case on
the right here is a little trickier
since it has no edge pieces lined up at
all what we always want to do is to get
the edge pieces so that they are paired
up with one another by pairing the edge
pieces we will eventually arrange them
so that they look like the previous
parody error since the parity error on
the left is a little easier I'm going to
go over that one first okay so as you'll
see we already have an edge pair here
for the red blue so we want to try to
get an edge pair for the yellow blue to
do that we need to match these two
pieces but we can't do that when they
have the same orientation to switch the
orientation I'm going to bring this
piece down put that piece over there and
then bring this piece back up now that
they have opposite orientation we can
match them up to match them up I'm going
to switch these two outer edge pieces by
using the algorithm we use in the
previous parody case
so we need to put these outer edge
pieces on the top face all the way to
the right now we can perform the
following algorithm both left faces
counterclockwise the up face 180 degrees
both left faces counterclockwise the up
face again 180 degrees the front face
180 degrees both left faces
counterclockwise the front face 180
degrees both right faces clockwise the
up face 180 degrees both right faces
counterclockwise the up face 180 degrees
and both left faces 180 degrees so as
you'll see we now have two edge pairs
which are already matched so now we do
is this is the exact same thing that we
had the previous parody case so we all
we have to do is align them so that both
of these single outer edge pieces are in
the same layer and then we perform the
algorithm again by holding them on the
right here so it's both left faces
counterclockwise up face 180 degrees
both left faces counterclockwise up face
180 degrees the front face 180 degrees
both left faces counterclockwise the
front face 180 degrees both right faces
clockwise the up face a hundred and
eighty degrees both right faces
counterclockwise the up face a hundred
and eighty degrees and both left faces
180 degrees and as you'll see that
parity error that we had there is now
corrected all right this last parody
case where there are no matched up edge
pieces is very similar to the other
parody case but you must perform the
algorithm three times instead of two I
will quickly show you how to correct it
however if you can fix the previous
case you could pretty much fix any
parity error you will see what we want
to do is make sure that these two pieces
have opposite orientations so that we
can match them and then we're going to
perform the algorithm we then want to
match these two pieces up by doing the
same thing so we put that piece all the
way on the right on top then all we have
to do is do the move one more time by
placing these two outer pieces on the
same layer then we could perform the
algorithm all right so now you'll see
that the parity case has been fixed
entirely with those algorithms you
should now be able to correct any parity
case you may see allowing you to solve
the cube exactly like a 3x3 just like I
demonstrated in the 4x4 tutorial step 3
if you have any questions or problems
please comment on the video and I'll be
glad to help you out I hope you found
the tutorial helpful and thanks for
watching